les chars de l'armée arabe syrienne
pénètre dans la ville de sarakeb située
au nord ouest du pays
après plusieurs jours de combats
acharnés cette petite ville est un lieu
stratégique de la province d'idlib
placé le long de l'autoroute m5 cet axe
routier prioritaire est depuis longtemps
dans le collimateur de damas afin de
mieux maîtriser le trafic routier allant
de la capitale syrienne à la seconde
ville du pays alep théâtre de violents
affrontements depuis la fin de la trêve
négociée par ankara et moscou en 2018
les forces armées syriennes ne veulent
pas se limiter à cette avancée
territoriale après l'encerclement de la
ville de saraqeb avec les unités
militaires
nous sommes entrés dans la ville qui est
devenu totalement sur l'armée poursuit
ses opérations vers la ville de sarmine
après avoir pris le contrôle de la ville
d'alès et si dieu le veut nous
continuerons vers la ville d'idlib et la
libération de tous les territoires de la
république arabe de syrie alliée de
certaines milices de la région la
turquie a réagi rapidement et envoyé un
convoi de 150 véhicules militaires
transportant troupes et équipements vers
ces points d'observation dans la
province une réponse légitime selon
l'armée turque
la riposte aux attaques a été menée dans
le cadre de la légitime défense
dorénavant apportera la réponse
appropriée à toute attaque et nos points
d'observation continueront leur mission
le président turc recep tayyip erdogan a
également appelé la russie alliée de la
syrie à faire pression pour qu'elle
cesse son offensive
une délégation russe a mené des
discussions en turquie samedi
elles doivent se poursuivre la semaine
prochaine dans le même temps l'envoyé
spécial de l'onu pour la syrie a appelé
à cesser le feu
guère pedersen s'est entretenu samedi
avec le ministre des affaires étrangères
iranien mohammad javad tarifs pour
tenter de trouver une solution politique
à la crise dans la région d'idlib